you believe in that like 11 and 11 make
a wish and stuff like that and no i
don't know that yeah
i got me on that one time i believe in
some good luck how long were you into it
for
like for two weeks i was like 11 11 make
a wish and then i
kept doing it huh but two and all those
two weeks two times i lost twenty
dollars
did you have any like uh uh what do you
call it
like when you were fighting did you have
any rituals no no oh well yeah well yeah
i just i if
i have to put on my cup before i get my
hands wrapped that was my ritual that
was it it was weird
i wanted to sit down want to sit down
with my cup while i get my hands wrapped
and that was i always wanted my right
hand wrapped first but it was never like
and then i remember when i was doing
golden gloves i'd always put my right
hand
in first and they forced me to put my
left hand first i'm like ah [ __ ]
wait and then i knocked the guy out and
that doesn't matter yeah yeah right
now you realize that [ __ ] but it's a
comment when you go to the right hand
first though
usually everyone puts the right hand
first yeah but then i was like yeah
forever and golden gloves they would
just like some dude get knocked out he'd
take his gloves off with sheer gloves
so then what a reason he was like yo and
only had the left hand i'm like
you didn't want to look at it like i was
like god damn it
have you ever seen his fights no bro
he's got a funny one on youtube where
he's just talking [ __ ]
the whole time to some dude and even
he's even talking [ __ ] to
uh the dude's trainers what really he's
like yeah i'm in
go great shape go to youtube go to
youtube
i think it's like mark oh yeah the more
guy i'm in great shape
hey for one let's just talk to talk
about the promotion company
they they uh oh wow look
wait look hold on look at mine
look at my dad look at me oh wow
i'm not even mad like i'm more look
let's just let's just
hold on i'm uh very anxious for this
fight tomorrow i'm as a mustache
153 i was going through something
fighting at 153 yeah 153
mentally prepared physically smart bazil
why they tell you mark well i don't know
the promotion company was like yo
like you know what we think mark we
realized what's your name malik malik i
was like no malik let me see his let me
see his opponent
oh carl carl carl killed me car killed
me
his intro was waving oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
turn it off
he killed me i'm coming from compton
california i'm coming out here you know
i'm ready to turn up
well this is so difficult this is i
don't know why y'all doing this
because it was hilarious right here turn
up here oh he killed me with the intro
look at his intro music oh
lean back with it carl oh no his intro
watch his intro
for one that's that's i i wasn't
prepared for him i ain't know how that
was going
he killed me you remember this song so
we have to cut the music which sucks
oh yeah yeah we cut it yeah he came out
killed bro he's ready he's ready for me
i know i was scared as hell this pro
yeah now this is the exhibition
uh okay was this in vegas this was
actually in uh
way up north in california i want to say
clemente all right what is it
clementine san clemente
hey i like the diversity in the crowd oh
yeah
yeah definitely like yeah that's what
you get from santa clamente
like while my mouth is like that my
mouthpiece didn't know this is so it was
a
last-minute training for this fight
without train yeah where um
actually be honest i'm not trying to
sound cocky i didn't train for this
fight
you didn't pay for this fight no because
it was the last minute exhibitions like
hey
we're putting on this like a great
benefit for charity or something like
that you want to be a part of it look
at [ __ ] look at
is why the shorts are so baggy it's so
strange yeah those are
like why wouldn't you want to move this
wasn't like i was about to say it's
it's flashier now look this is what in
2012 though
this flash here now like you see like
earl's business decision or do you stop
it no no no
dude i kind of yeah we could fast
forward but uh i walk off this one says
that was it that was it that was it i
gotta get here
wait a minute wait a minute okay you're
for real you're literally fighting
this whole fight but yeah it's just me
talking i was like all right well cause
because i wasn't in shape and i was like
this dude is big and he's strong and he
like i i guess he uh
he from compton what you want me to do
didn't throw a lot of punches
no he doesn't oh he doesn't know i'm
throwing one punch this entire secret he
didn't i'm so thankful he did brilliant
true god yeah the confidence but that
was it yeah that was a whole and i won
uh we won the exhibition and uh i was
like yo
after the fight he was like bro he
really wanted to fight true story
oh you have to fight like afterwards
yeah i was like wait like i was like bro
this footbed that's for charity
like nah man you was talking all that
just talking about you talking about
[ __ ]
and i couldn't get in my shell [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the ring i was like bro you had
four rounds
you had only four it was only four
rounds there's only four yeah i fast
forward to uppercut all the way at the
end i hit him with a good uppercut and i
think that's what like they
uh go was his corner talking [ __ ] today
yeah we were talking
both of the corners yeah and it was
funny i was like bro this is for chair
because you were like i'm in great shape
i mean
what did they shout at you they were
like he ain't in shape he ain't in shape
he was like yo
he ain't throw punches i was like well
by the way
all wearing beanies to say turn up
which
[Applause]
my corner he had dreads i was like okay
we not we didn't look at
good as a oh here i think he's coming
right here right here with the uppercut
i'm sorry this dude throwing punches
he hit me right now you know
this the one right here this the one
right there this one right here wait
wait wait wait that that this is the one
that want me to fight
right here oh
come on why you hit him
doing the choo-choo trick watching my
legs wait i think i wanted to walk over
there but my legs was like hold on let's
take a second
and then his corner started talking [ __ ]
he's talking he was like yo he tired for
real now
look at his legs i was like wait no i
think it was
and that was that was the that was the
end of the fight that was that
that wanted me to hear his stuff yo he
really wanted to fight me out there she
was like yeah what you were saying in
the ring i was like bro that was in the
ring
that's hilarious right afterwards
and they wanted to fight you out yeah
they wanted to fight so the quarter
because remember the coroners was
talking to each other and stopped yeah
nonstop
and it's always weird when they want to
fight after afterwards i'm like bro he
was like did you hear that
uh no no no never will you finish him
you we get paid to do this why would i
do it for free out here
yeah true yeah makes no sense i was like
bro you got all these good ass white
people in the crowd don't make a
decision
come on man don't do that don't do that
bro i'm trying to get a business
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this is from a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son